I was reading about your parents oh yeah
and your dad and your mom and how she
worked at Wawa and how your dad had like
this amazing work ethic and you like
maybe run a mile a minute because of
that because you were raised in that
yeah my parents were really young when
they had me my mom was 19 I believe when
she got pregnant with me and my parents
came from nothing they were like
Hustlers so I think I have that in my
blood because I grew up like watching
them hustle and you know my mom went to
night school and became a lawyer both of
my parents are they both worked at Wawa
I think at one time together my mom was
like the manager or something yeah
but I love that you like did not come
from any connections or leg up like how
did you what was your first in like my
whole like introduction into Hollywood
and stuff was so fast like it was almost
like it doesn't happen like that
normally like I auditioned for funny
people which is a Judd Aptoide movie
that Adam Sandler of course was in where
I play a stand-up comedian and then I
got Parks and Rec and then I got Scott
Pilgrim all in the same week
um I know that's crazy I know it doesn't
happen like that it was like I can
literally pinpoint like when people are
like what's your big break I'm like
literally like one week one week that
week three jobs one week three jobs one
week and I've been working ever since is
it true that you saw Ryan Gosling in a
juice bar I was beyond a dork because I
didn't recognize her he was beefed up
because I think he had just done Drive
which is the best movie and he was
staring at me and smiling what did he
say what did he tell he didn't say
anything he just smiled at me and then I
was the idiot and I did that thing that
people do to celebrities where they're
like I know you we've worked together we
must have worked together and I was like
you just I know like we've I know you
and he was like smiling just like he had
like a secret and he was just like you
don't know me and then
um and then I said what's your name and
he said Ryan and I said I know we know
each other Ryan and he was like we don't
and then he left and the minute he left
I was like Ryan Gosling Ryan gossing
Gosling Gosling Gosling and then it was
over must have been I mean literally 10
years ago okay speaking of 10 years ago
you are married we've talked about your
wedding yeah your wonderful husband 12
years you guys have been together
okay what is the key to making a
relationship work I feel like there's
two things that come to mind one is the
amount of time we spend apart I think
makes us always
stay together because we're it's like
you're always kind of re I don't know
like falling in love with each other or
something and I'm also like I think he's
married to someone that is like I'm
always like look I'm I'm blonde like
what is happening like by the way you
have a great blonde too because really
because I'm like fantastic it's really
the most beautiful tone the funniest
thing too is that the day that I was
going blonde guess who walked in to get
her touch up oh Amy Poehler
yes and I hadn't seen her and we're like
really good friends and I hadn't seen
her in forever and I was like Amy I'm
going blonde and she sat there held my
hand and she was like we're sisters you
know it was really cute do you keep in
touch with them yeah actually you know
they all we were all in like a little
text change you are that's with my
fantasy we are and like today Adam Scott
and I both got nominated for Golden
Globe awards I was gonna get to that
[Applause]
it was like it's so heartwarming because
everybody texted and they were like
congrats you know whenever anything good
happens like at you know we all like
it's like a family I said like I love
you fam it was so nice I mean how does
it feel I don't know do you think your
parents are proud of you yeah of course
my actually my mom texted me last night
after she watched the finale and was
like you're gonna get she was like you
and Jennifer Coolidge are gonna get a
nomination or whatever
um whatever Mom and then I woke up this
morning and she was right and she's like
you me and Jennifer
[Music]